and how are the old time keepers
how do you think i don't know because
i've never met them
part of the fun of this is still looking
at the theories
and jumping in and being like what's
this who could this be blah blah blah
so we're going to talk about some of the
theories that are coming up about the
show and you let you let me know what
you think about them
the number one theory that i'm kind of
on board with right now
is that there is no time keepers
and that it is just kang what do you
guys think about that one
so why won't you tell me how many people
are guarding the time keepers
i'm not sure if i believe there are no
time keepers
i certainly believe that the timekeepers
are not
what we have been told that they are so
i i'm not a hundred percent sure
it seemed like in this episode there is
something
unique waiting at the top of the golden
elevator um
whether that is kang or something
different entirely
i'm not a hundred percent sure yet but i
think people are on to something with
the uh
something that ain't right with the time
keepers i agree with that i
i'm not sure if kang would be completely
tied because
to this point they have it one-to-one
tied what's happened in the disney plus
um shows
directly to uh a movie
because kang is gonna appear in quantum
mania
so what they make that reveal now i
can't always shut the door on your
theory
because maybe this is the one where they
pick to
to show kang off kind of like how they
built with thanos
throughout the infinity saga right i i
actually think
ravona knows what's going on i don't
think she's a variant
i think she is the right hand of
whoever the timekeepers or timekeeper is
if it's not her so
i'm like halfway in on on your theory
carlos
the idea that your little club decides
the fate of trillions of people across
all of existence at the best of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
richard e grant we love richard grant
richard again is amazing
but we don't know who richard rand is
going to be now again going back to the
pistol thing people were like oh maybe
pistol doing this whole thing and he
would be a great you know whatever he'd
be afraid of playing like the devil
people want to say and i think this is a
good one richie grant is actually
that future evil loki the one that we
haven't seen in the mcu at all the one
that we're
you know that we're used to seeing this
loki from the comic books right with the
big horns and just and the big ponytail
maybe they won't do that visually
but imagine that richie grant is
actually loki pulling all the strings
as the head of this tva that he might
have created
what are your thoughts on that sam i
think that you have some i mean
if you look at a picture of richard
grant and tom hiddleston side by side
it is almost unavoidable
like the comparison is there they look
deeply similar
like you could see where you would be an
aged up version of tom hiddleston now
that being said
sylvie looks nothing like john hills say
for the accent
so perhaps that means nothing at all and
it is yet another red herring
but i i find this one very convincing
personally it would be really dope to
see that version of loki because that's
what
i grew up with like tom hiddleston is
like
putting loki on the cover of gq or or
or one of those magazines he's like the
gqueued up version
the younger version but we haven't seen
that
older maniacal the the
god of mischief the one whose mischief
does include
mass murder and execution and whatever
he wants
to to reach his goal so i i think that
would be
that would be pretty interesting if this
is all of
one big plot by him being the puppeteer
that moves all the strings right
i think that would be pretty interesting
and i think it's also
funny that we keep talking about
mephisto right because
i think about um like the greatest trick
the devil ever pulled
right it was convincing people he he
doesn't exist but i think in this case
he's convincing
us that he does does exist
right like because everybody's convinced
so when he does finally appear
i think they're gonna do it in a way
that we don't expect and we're like oh
it was mephisto
yeah we get to the top of that elevator
and it's boner at the top
it was me it was me guys